just to let them know that they're not
alone we love you Janet Jackson but your
popularity has dipped ever since your
wardrobe malfunction during your 2004
Super Bowl performance you handled the
scandal in a very mature way and we all
know that it wasn't your fault
but some of your fans weren't as
convinced you managed to make a comeback
which is why you don't belong in this
list but the 10 celebs who do just
weren't as lucky as you the world like
hated me for this SNL moment I had
celebrities are constantly being watched
everything they do and say can find its
way online and their fame can take a
total hit if they're filmed saying
something controversial they can be
chased out of Hollywood without a
moment's notice keep watching to find
out which rapper was so dramatic on
Twitter her account had to be
deactivated Fergie Fergie has been a
household name ever since she made waves
as Black Eyed Peas female vocalist she
eventually went solo and won the award
for best female artists at MTV's Music
Video Awards in 2007 but in 2018 Fergie
would make headlines for an entirely
different reason
Fergie sang a slowed down version of the
star-spangled banner at an NBA all-star
game and her performance totally tanked
it was so bad members of the audience
and NBA players alike couldn't help but
laugh out loud Fergie's popularity took
a direct hit and some might even say
that she destroyed her career on live
television
Jake Paul Jake Paul is one of the most
famous youtubers out there so much so
that in 2015 he scored a deal with
Disney and was all set to star on
bizarre vark everything was going great
until Jake bought himself a mansion in
Los Angeles and began terrorizing his
neighbors Jake filmed tons of stunts
around his neighborhood and uploaded
them to YouTube but unfortunately for
Jake the disruption he caused was a
major red flag for Disney oh I hope
you're not mad I did it they felt that
Jake was sending a bad message to his
followers so Disney immediately cut ties
with Jake ruining his chances for a
successful TV career Amy Schumer Amy
Schumer is hilarious there's no doubt
about it but according to some of her
fans and fellow comedians she's a total
joke thief amy has denied every single
one of these allegations but the proof
is in the pudding in 2015 while amy was
performing her live at the Apollo
stand-up routine
you want to get a popcorn and I'll be
like oh my god I hadn't even thought
about it she used one of Patrice
O'Neal's jokes eh me and Patrice her
friends so fans do not believe that she
did this innocently since then amy has
lost a lot of fans but that's nothing
she can't handle Nick Cannon Nick Cannon
is a well-known celebrity and a
jack-of-all-trades his popularity
skyrocketed a few years back but
everything changed when Nick used
inappropriate language during a comedy
special on Showtime as the host of
America's Got Talent Nick was supposed
to maintain a pristine image which he
failed to do so unfortunately his
contract was terminated by NBC
executives but I never want to play the
victim
Nick added fuel to the fire by posting a
series of tweets that would later come
back to haunt him Iggy Azalea anyone who
follows Iggy on Twitter is well aware
that the artist doesn't shy away from
controversial topics but some of her
rude and unjustified tweets have
backfired on her big time like when Iggy
was all set to perform at the Pittsburgh
gay pride event but had to pull out when
the LGBTQ community protested against
her performance Jenny slate back in 2009
Jenny slate performed a skit on SNL and
totally messed up her lines she
mistakenly dropped the f-word when she
was supposed to say a variation of it
jenny was let go after just one season
and according to the actress she had a
tough time landing roles after the
mishap it kind of embarrasses me
kendall Jenner kendall jenner may be a
successful model and influencer but her
infamous Pepsi commercial was nothing
short of catastrophic the reality TV
star received a lot of backlash for
starring in this controversial
commercial back in 2018 and her
reputation suffered greatly from it if I
knew this I would have never done
something like this but she's kendall
Jenner
so she eventually bounced back Cee Lo
Green
in 2010 Cee Lo Green gained recognition
with his breakthrough song forget you
but by 2014 the world would forget all
about him and for good reasons to CeeLo
posted an outrageous tweet about consent
taking away from the tragic experiences
of survivors of assault Cee Lo
immediately lost his gig on The Good
Life and the voice and all of his tours
were canceled
sinker CeeLo green charge was slippin
ecstasy to a woman Ashlee Simpson back
in 2004 Ashlee Simpson was all set to
become the next big thing well until she
performed live on SNL and was caught
lip-synching she panic and tried to
dance the embarrassment away which only
added to the fiasco
Ashlee singing career took a hit that
she never recovered from for me was the
most humbling experience of my life
Azealia Banks and last but certainly not
least as the famed rapper
Azealia Banks who seemingly ruined her
career after a slew of racist and
homophobic tweets she lost plenty of
fans as a result and her Twitter account
was immediately deactivated every day is
difficult are you subscribed to the
things yet if not click that big red
subscribe button to join in on the fun
we post daily videos all about your
favorite celebs TV series and movies so
click the bell icon and turn on post
notifications to be the first to watch
our latest videos watching on your
mobile go on YouTube settings and turn
on notifications this way you'll always
be in the loop and that's a wrap on the
10 celebs who destroyed their careers on
live TV which stars action shocked you
the most sound off in the comments
section thanks for watching don't forget
to give this video a big thumbs up we'll
see you next time